[Music]
the first question many ask when they
see a unique picture that just went
viral is but it's photoshopped right and
they kind of have a point over the years
the Internet has seen many awesome
pictures that turned out to be Photoshop
but stay tuned as we will show you some
of the most amazing photos that didn't
need the Photoshop magic wait until you
see a cloud in a room you'll start to
believe that anything can become true if
you're new to our channel don't forget
to click the red subscribe button to see
more videos like this one now join us as
we discuss ten amazing pictures you
won't believe aren't photoshopped the
half bursting bubble this must be fake
right it's very hard to believe that
this image is even a photograph in the
first place but it is the man behind the
picture is a famous photographer Richard
heaps and what he's known for is his
soap bubble photography on this picture
you can see a finger popping a bubble
but Richard managed to capture the
bubble just as half of its shape turned
into droplets so what's the story behind
this one well first of all the hand with
the pointed finger you see belongs to
his wife Richard said he was always
fascinated with spheres and reflections
he only discovered soap bubble
photography when one day his nieces
started blowing bubbles in the backyard
he captured one of the popping bubbles
just at the right time and it inspired
him so much he started experimenting
with bubble photography the photo that
you see actually has a lot more going on
than just a burst of a bubble look
closer you're also able to see Richards
reflection and the reflection of his
wife as she's popping the bubble the
photo received a lot of positive
feedback and Richard started getting
requests from newspapers and magazines
that were very eager to feature his work
you can find all of his amazing
photography work online the Blue Angels
formation if this were really multiple
planes flying that close together what
did they end up hitting each other
you'll be surprised to learn that this
picture is totally real and it belongs
to the Blue Angels the US Navy's flight
demonstration squadron although any
other planes that fly this close
together might crash this is completely
normal for the Blue Angels their history
dates back to when the team was first
formed in 1949 since then they started
gaining a reputation for their
spectacular aerobatic maneuvers there
are 11 Jets currently in the squadron
and through the
years there have been two hundred and
sixty one demonstration pilots in total
blue angels jets can travel the speed of
up to 700 miles per hour and during
their shows you will see them perform
their aerobatics sometimes just 18
inches apart their shows are always
incredible and this picture alone can
prove that in fact 11 million spectators
see their shows every year with an
additional 50,000 from March through
November the purpose of their shows is
to showcase the pride and
professionalism of the United States
Navy and Marine Corp they want to
inspire a culture of excellence and
service to country through flight
demonstration and community outreach and
it's certainly working a hole in the sky
there's probably a better way to
describe this fascinating photo than
saying there's a cloud hole in the sky
with a rainbow you might even think that
it belongs to a UFO sighting luckily
there's a way better explanation to this
phenomenon this formation is completely
natural and definitely not photoshopped
this particular photograph was taken in
eastern Victoria in Australia so here's
how sky holes like this one happen the
water temperature and the clouds has to
reach a freezing point but is not yet
frozen due to the lack of ice nucleation
what actually creates this hole is
called the Bergeron process which causes
the water droplets around a large number
of ice crystals to evaporate these ice
crystals often form when a plane passes
through the cloud and cools the air
the rainbow you can see on the picture
is just a beautiful effect caused by the
droplets and the Sun this phenomenon has
many different names such as cave um
hole-punch cloud sky punch and false
tree pole if you see one of these
impressive clouds one day make sure you
take a picture and show it to your
friends they'll think you have amazing
photoshop skills ants forming a bridge
it's hard to believe that ads would be
able to stay in such position without
managing to fall right believe it or not
this picture is 100% real and it was
taken by a photographer called a deep
Ryoga Adi posted a series of photos
showing an army of ants that were
stranded in a tree thinking they could
go further the ants quickly realized
they've reached the end of the branch
and started doing some serious damage
control instead of climbing back down
they were determined in a very
impressive real-life scenario the 0.03
inch long ants work
together and created their own bridge to
make it to the other parts of the tree
what you see on the picture are ants
locking legs and making their very own
and bridge to reach the other side and
if you didn't think this is possible let
us remind you how smart insects like
ants bees and termites actually are they
keep track of the distance and the
direction traveled so they can always
know the best way to come back home
this photo is an example of ants
evaluating the situation and working
together to efficiently fix the problem
do you think they actually made it
across busy ants up close let's take it
one step further and debunk some more
pictures people think or Photoshop when
it comes to ant photography we can
totally see how these pictures could
make people think they are staged but
they are not they're just very very
creative they belong to a talented
Russian photographer who goes by the
name of Andrew Pavlov and Rebbe decided
to take on ant macro photography after
he studied ants and got inspired by how
they care for their community including
their weaker members he noticed all ants
have specific work patterns and followed
the same path when they work although he
does spice up his pictures with a prop
and spends a few hours setting up these
scenes to really capture the moment it's
actually the ants that take advantage of
the props they are given and Ravello p--
interesting macro photography series he
calls ant tales they document insects
doing regular daily life activities in
their natural environment through these
photographs these smart creatures are
showing us there is more to them than
just crawling around so next time you
see an end don't step on it grab your
camera and observe how they move in
their community add a prop here or there
and you'll be surprised what ants can do
optical illusion in Paris this looks
totally photoshopped right a sphere that
looks like the earth casually standing
on the street you can even see there's
something not right with this picture
the trees and the people far away are
actually it but believe it or not this
picture is real it's a sculpture that's
actually an impressive optical illusion
created by parisian artist francois a
blonde a it looks like a sphere but it's
completely flat what you see is called
3d street art one of the most
fascinating art forms with amazing
effects look at it from a wrong angle
and you might see something completely
different this sphere might look small
but look at it again closely now that
you know it's art
see how bard stretches and how small the
people look on the other side
it covers 1,500 square meters which is
about sixteen thousand square feet
what's so cool about this one is that it
uses real grass that took 90 gardeners
five days to assemble you can only see
the magic if you stand at the right
angle how amazing is that the piece is
called who to believe and you can find
it outside of Paris city hall if you go
to Paris make sure you visit the Eiffel
Tower but this impressive piece of art
should also be on your bucket list
this animal fluff ball we bet you think
there's no way this one's not
photoshopped right because if it's not
where is it possible to get these fluffy
creatures their heads disappear into
their fur hold on to your seats because
this picture is 100% real what you see
is the giant angora rabbit which is one
of the fluffiest rabbits and the largest
from the angora family these rabbits can
weigh up to ten pounds and we bet most
of that weight comes from their long fur
which needs to be frequently brushed as
a breed the giant Angora rabbits are
very rare and on the list of endangered
species their fur is very special and
needs to be harvested three to four
times a year the giant Angora rabbits
come in many different colors but the
only color recognized by the american
rabbit breeders Association is white
owning one of these fluff balls as pets
can be quite a challenge for non
experienced rapid owners as they require
much larger houses they feel best when
they're outdoors and we bet they require
a lot more cuddles than any other
rabbits you've seen but the air is so
cute that it is certainly worth it can
you imagine having one of these cute
fluffy creatures roaming around your
backyard we would definitely love to
have one to frying-pan on a beach if
you've never been to Sydney's Tamarama
you'd probably shrug off this pictures
just another Photoshop but there
actually was a frying pan on a beach and
it's picture is 100% real it's one of
the most unique and unexpected
sculptures you'll ever come across and
it belongs to an annual outdoor
sculpture exhibition called sculpture by
the sea in Sydney and Perth it all
started back in 1996 and this exhibition
is spread over 1.2 miles from Bondi
Beach to tamarama beach artists from all
over the world come to feature their
sculptures one of those was Andrew
Hankins giant 78 feet long frying pan
which he named were frying out here
the sculpture is an awareness of dangers
that come with sunbathing and a reminder
to not overcook yourself this summer
visitors are invited to go inside the
pan or walk on it and its handle was
designed for children to climb on
unfortunately this is only a temporary
exhibition if you want to catch unusual
objects on a beach for your own
photography portfolio make sure to check
out the dates for the sculpture by the
sea event an ocean inside a stone this
image is so detailed it's almost always
shrugged off as something that just
can't exist in real life but again what
you see here is a national gemstone of
Australia called opal and it's pretty
special because of its internal
structure it's able to diffract light
from the conditions under which it was
formed you can easily find colored opals
out there but finding an ocean inside
these opals is rare even for these
unique mineraloid the stunning opal
comes from opal but a mine in Oregon it
is amongst the most beautiful on the
market if you look at the opal closer
you will see it so detailed it's
impossible to be fake from the light
ocean shimmer to seaweed this is a rare
opal shown in its dry State but what's
even more magical is that you can only
see those images when you hold your opal
to light the visual effect is often
unexpected and adds on as an extra
surprise for the buyer you never know
your opal might show you a whole
aquarium inside a cloud inside a room
we've talked about frying pans on a
beach unusual behaving ends weird UFO
looking holes in the sky so where do we
draw the line what if we told you the
image of a cloud inside a room is real
yes it belongs to an artist that goes by
the name of bird nuts milled
who is known to make perfect miniature
clouds for indoor locations as unusual
as this might seem bird knot has become
quite famous for his sculptures and
devoted past several years of his life
to these cloud series he calls Nimbus
it's even more special about these
pictures is that his sculptures only
last 10 seconds these clouds only form
under specific conditions smoke water
vapor and a cold damp space with no air
condition so how does this happen he
uses a houseplant spritzer to create a
wall of water vapor then a smoke machine
sends a puff of a cloud on the wall he
likes to keep his clouds textured with
the length of no bigger than six feet
but the image that you see took a lot of
work and one
you might take 100 clouds to get the
picture he's looking for what's your
favorite picture that's 100% real let us
know in the comment section below
don't forget to subscribe and watch the
first part of our amazing pictures you
won't believe aren't photoshopped videos
[Music]